wallstreet she discusses the book with
senator Bernie Sanders of Vermont Mr
Sanders who was a US congressman for 16
years before moving to the Senate is the
author of the memoir outsider in the
house let me begin by thanking c-span
for the opportunity to be interviewing
Nomi Prins who was the author of it
takes a pillage behind the bailouts
bonuses and backroom deals from
Washington to Wall Street when I was in
the house for 16 years I served on the
Financial Services Committee so I have
something they already with this issue
and needless to say I have been actively
involved in it in the last three years
in the Senate
nobody thank you very much for being
with us today well thank you very much
and thank you for taking the time to be
here as well today senator let's begin
with a little bit of background about
you where were you born and what
happened in your life to end up to have
you end up on Wall Street and write the
books that you've written well I was
born in upstate New York and in
Poughkeepsie right outside of Vassar
College where my father had at one point
been a professor and then he was I'm
working in research at IBM there it was
very much an IBM town at the time and we
were very much as a mathematical type of
family a lot of work with numbers from
from a very very young age
and I ultimately want to go into a state
school to SUNY Purchase a little closer
to New York City getting closer to Wall
Street to some extent where I studied
mathematics and I minored in music but
my father said math is really the way to
get a decent living and you know find a
job and as it turned out that was that
was true because ultimately that was
what was being hired on Wall Street at
the time a lot of math and engineering
and computer science were really the
degrees that the street was looking for
and so what I really just wanted to do
is move to New York as you do when you
graduate college and
I wound up getting my first job at Chase
Manhattan Bank before it was part of
JPMorgan Chase when I graduated actually
before I graduated even I was I was 19 I
sort of did a transition chief yes I was
a man I started there doing a lot of
analysis and sort of computer work and
in numerical work on what was why but
others are partying and having a great
time did you end up like this I was way
too serious I was the oldest child in
the family and I think that might have
had something to do with it that sort of
sense of responsibility and financial
independence and everything else I think
I somehow wound up over there and I
figured that was only gonna be there for
a year or two and sort of work in
musical theatre or something else in New
York instead and as it turned out I
wound up staying there a very long time
through a number of different firms and
I think it just became just easy to some
extent with all of the hardness that
comes with Wall Street and within Wall
Street firms you did make enough money
to pay rent in New York City and
everything else nothing like the kinds
of sums that are being made today but
certainly enough to to live on your own
let me ask you this I mean you write
your book in a sense as being in the
belly of the beast so to speak you were
there so what impact on your views on
your life views about Wall Street
occurred as a result of your working for
Goldman Sachs how many years did you
work for Goldman Sachs I was the Goldman
Sachs for two years it was the end of my
career on Wall Street I actually ejected
myself from Wall Street after having
been at Goldman Sachs the best I worked
in as well and embarrass turns as well I
was over in London actually for Bear
Stearns around an analytics group there
for seven years so that was really the
crux of a lot of the work I was doing on
Wall Street and internationally and then
I came to Boulder
so what impacted your experience on Wall
Street have on your views what do you
like you're on the inside most of us are
not on the inside one of the things you
know on the inside and you learn on the
inside is there is such a tremendously
competitive environment which which
there aren't a lot of other places but
it but in Wall Street it's almost like
you come in every single day and the
higher you move up in a firm the more
this is the case every single day trying
to figure out how much
credit you can take for a particular
trade if you can beat someone on another
desk or in another area of the firm you
actually race to the offices of senior
management in order to be able to tell
them what you did to take part in a
certain deal or a transaction and very
much becomes this immediate type of an
environment where if you don't do that
you don't succeed and if you're someone
who who wants to try and succeed you
sort of get involved in this game and I
ultimately found that very distasteful
and really quite empty but but the
environment is very much like that it's
it's very intense from a gamesmanship
and a power sort of play as well as it's
really like a military strategy almost
every day going in its literally from
whose name you put on an email first to
whose office you go into first to who
you tell about a certain trade before
someone else knows like United States
Congress but let me ask you let me ask
you a question I think that it's on the
minds of millions of Americans right now
we are in the most serious economic
decline since the Great Depression if
you add up the number of people who are
unemployed underemployed and given up
looking for work 17 percent of the
American adult workforce isn't that
position it is a disaster people have
lost their homes they've lost their
savings they lost their pensions all
because in my view at least of the greed
of the people on Wall Street now one of
the first question I want to ask you is
some people say well nobody could have
predicted this my god it just came out
of the blue it was just amazing totally
unpredictable how do you respond to that
it was absolutely predictable for a lot
of reasons one is that that mentality in
the street
the reason this crisis happened was
because there was a desire to find
products and to create assets within
Wall Street that made money and they
don't really care it doesn't matter to
Wall Street firms what those assets are
it turned out that they created assets
out of a small amount of subprime loans
and when I say a small amount I look at
it like it's an upside down pyramid
where at the bottom point you have
subprime loans and one point four
trillion oh those were issued during
2002 to 2007 but what Wall Street does
is it takes the
and it creates new securities this whole
other band of securities and from those
it can make fees it can make trading
commissions in a lot of other profits
they made 300 billion dollars just on
creating securities out of these loans
not on even training them back and forth
just on the sheer creation of these
securities during those same years and
then what they do is they take those
securities they borrow against them to
create new ones and to merge and to
acquire and to trade and to speculate so
it all goes up or that's why this whole
thing fell down it wasn't that the
subprime loans got wrong it was that all
of the securities and trading on top of
them toppled over you know what I think
most people kind of scratch their head
and when they went to school and we
learned about economics you say somebody
start some business and maybe they maybe
they sell automobiles and maybe they
sell clocks maybe they sell shoes maybe
they manufacture these things so here's
my really tough question here what the
hell do they do on Wall Street what do
they make what do they produce well they
produce assets that only have value
because they choose to say that they
have value there is your life of my kids
lives it absolutely doesn't and that's a
really good analysis of the street that
Wall Street's
exists in particularly investment banks
and the most speculative components of
banks exist purely to create to engineer
that's what they talk it's engineering
assets it's not engineering a train
track it's not engineering a building
it's engineering something that only has
value because they say it does and and
it it gets its value from from that I
have a quote in my book which is great
from the senior partner at Goldman Sachs
who left the firm to actually go to
Morgan Stanley and it was quite senior
there who said it's one of the only
finance is one of the only arts that's
basically our science is created
predicated on the creation of absolutely
nothing and it's only by pushing that
none thing for something throughout the
system because people continue to buy it
that this continues to churn and you
create these sort of upside-down
pyramids of risk and assets that don't
truly have intrinsic value so at a time
when manufacturing capability is
declining well we've lost millions of
good manufacturing jobs our
infrastructure is in major disrepair we
desperately need scientists to help us
deal with illnesses etc etc we're seeing
some of the best minds in the country
going into a sphere of activity which
produces virtually nothing that is
useful to the ordinary person it is not
useful to the ordinary person it is
purely the amount of profit if you look
at a company like goldman sachs the top
tier investment firm they pay almost 50
percent of their profits out in bonuses
in another in any type of production
company or even retail company the
amount of money that's paid in terms of
compensation is maybe 20% or 22% so all
of that extra fluff all of that extra
profit that's really just about moving
transactions or really moving money back
and forth goes directly into these
extravagant bonuses and extravagant
compensation structures it doesn't go
out anymore it doesn't even pretend to
go out anywhere it stays right there and
it looks to me like we're developing two
separate worlds and I can't remember the
figure I think was like something like
40% of the profits in America are now
being made on Wall Street rather an
extraordinary number it's an
extraordinary of course in in in New
York City it's it's an even greater
proportion of what what revenue comes
into the city and it's an obscene number
because it's really not predicated on
the creation of anything we're still
talking about assets that pretend to
have value and that are rated to have
value there's there's all these other
agencies that work with Wall Street like
the rating agencies like S&P and like
Moody's and they come in they basically
stamp value by deciding that these
assets are worth a certain amount or
that they have a certain quality
attached to them they call it triple-a
and if you call something triple-a it
sounds really good and investors buy it
and pension funds by it and States buy
it and individuals hear about it from
their local bankers and and so basically
this infiltrates the entire system I
remember I remember the budget committee
now and we had Hank Paulson and a couple
of years ago and I said mr. Paulson back
in my state of Vermont around this
country the middle class is on a whole
lot of trouble people are really
struggling people
losing their jobs their income is going
down as a growing gap between the very
rich and everybody else what's your
sense of the economy and he said all the
economy is not really good and year
after year and this is really astounding
had a bit of a ting year after year we
heard from the Bush administration that
from their perspective the economy was
doing great
now explain to me how they could believe
the economy was doing great when the
middle class was collapsing and we were
getting closer and closer and closer to
the edge of a major global financial
crisis because for them it was great and
that's the problem 2006 was the record
year of bonuses on Wall Street 2006 now
between 2006 and 2007 foreclosures in
this country just between March 2006 in
March 2007 foreclosures increased by 47%
so it isn't like there wasn't
information coming in that would
indicate there was a tremendous problem
brewing and it's not like someone like
Treasury secretary at the time Hank
Paulson who had been a CEO of goldman
sachs and understands numbers could not
have seen that but the fact is Goldman
and other firms were paying out record
bonuses that year because they were
manufacturing as things were getting
weaker and they knew this they were
manufacturing an even greater amount of
these assets because they sort of wanted
to turn it all in and sort of take
profits as much as they could as soon as
they could because they actually knew
things weren't going to continue to stay
Wall Street knew there was a less
trading going on in some of these which
was why they were created more these
ultimately these toxic assets because
Wall Street knew that the game might be
up and so they pay themselves well they
created these assets and Paulson should
have known this the Fed should have
known this because on the other side of
all of this was declining loans was
increasing foreclosures increasing
defaults this was real data yeah I got
to tell you from my ends of the street
so to speak sitting in the Congress and
hearing these guys talk it's like they
were living in another world where you
had Bernanke himself who now chairman of
the Fed who for a while was the major
economic adviser to the president I
didn't hear anything coming from these
guys that say wait a second we got to do
something
we don't act we may have the collapse of
finance in the United States and around
the world where were they at this point
well that's it I don't think they were
looking at this date or if they were
they were choosing to ignore it or to
act optimistic because that served a
political agenda because you don't you
don't want to be the party in power when
the crisis happened so if you can sort
of push along and sort of will it to not
happen and sort of give this and this is
how I look at it from the outside but
given optimistic spin on things even
with negative data coming in you can
sort of push it on to to really the next
guy or the next administration or the
next Fed out he almost got it happened
just in the beginning of 2009 it would
have changed but the reality was all
this stuff was brewing talk about for a
moment this whole business of
deregulation my understanding is that
during a ten year period Wall Street
spent about five billion dollars
pressuring Congress through lobbying
efforts through campaign contributions
to deregulate it away with
glass-steagall etc etc what impact that
all of that deregulation allowing these
mergers to take place have on the
ensuing financial collapse well the
repeal of glass-steagall was really the
catalyst for what ultimately became a
decade later the collapse and and
actually what even became a few years
later some Enron and World Cup and alike
to forget about because they were all
predicated on the idea of merging and
acquiring and banking institutions
becoming not just bigger which they were
doing or was a record merger spree as
well leading into the repeal of
glass-steagall which which happened
almost a year ago today on November 12
1999 was when glass-steagall was
repealed I voted against that let me let
me make the record clear well not only
did you vote against it I think you also
said that all the things that would
happen to consumers to mergers all of
that I dig a bit facetiously but it did
happen I mean all of the warning signs
unfortunately came into fruition and the
reason for that is that when banks
merged and when concentration changes so
that the more powerful ones have more
deposits and control more loans and
control more actual capital they
they can trade it they can speculate
with it because it is there and so
that's what ultimately caused the crisis
is that you had extra capital and extra
access to consumers that you could use
real money in real loans and real assets
and turn them into something that
ultimately became a crisis I'm gonna
move you a little bit and ask you a
question here's an interesting question
during those years when I was a member
of the Financial Services Committee
every year Alan Greenspan would come out
and after everybody rolled out the red
carpet and God had walked into the
chamber and you cannot believe I believe
me there was and and Greenspan gave
forth his libertarian philosophy that
the best thing that we can possibly do
is the way with all government
regulation and when you allow these guys
on Wall Street do anything they want
somehow this wealth and do all the right
things that it's going to create great
wealth for all the American some of us
of course did not believe it but
unfortunately a majority of the people
believed in now here's my political
question for you which is interesting
and I think maybe says a whole lot about
our political system the president who
originally appointed Alan Greenspan was
the first president Bush and he was
reappointed and the first president Bush
was considered to be maybe a
center-right type of politician he was
reappointed and you know Greenspan is an
extreme right-wing guy by a liberal
Democrat named Bill Clinton then you had
some years later mr. Bernanke is
appointed by kind of a right-wing
Republican named George W Bush and a
liberal Democrat wants to reappoint him
what's going on people I generally
believe that there's a difference in
opinion between a first Bush and a
Clinton and a second Bush and an Obama
how does this happen
well well first of all there there
hasn't been really a change in any of
the regulations that come on to the
financial world between any any of those
two administration changes unfortunately
we hope there will be Rebecca let me
back them up she's raising a very
interesting point and maybe I speak as
an independent here yeah it was not a
democrat or republican but what you're
essentially saying that while there are
differences obviously everyday between
Democrats and Republicans at least kind
of key
financial issues about how we deal with
Wall Street and who's head of the Fed
does not seem to be a heck of a lot of
difference it's not kind of what you're
suggesting it seems like one of the the
least partisan things in in Washington
because if you look at just the sheer
regulations that were passed that the
continuation of Fed Chairman under under
the changes from Republican to Democrat
both times
there isn't a tremendous amount of
difference in fact there was more
financial deregulation done under
Clinton than there was underneath and
the first secretary of the Treasury then
yes who happened to have also been a co
CEO at one point of goldman sachs which
is a whole other issue this revolving
door from Wall Street and it so happens
from Goldman Sachs into the presidency
whether or not there is a Democrat or a
Republican presentation was also at
Paulson who was when I was there he what
he was he was my boss yes he was head of
Goldman Sachs became Treasury secretary
he was a Republican under Bush - who was
a Republican but Bob Rubin of course was
a Democrat under Clinton who was a
Democrat but they were both for the same
deregulation you could have almost
interchanged them at any point in time
when Tim Geithner where was Tim well Tim
of course well if we talk about where he
was in terms of the bailout and
everything else he was head of the New
York Fed which had a very tight
relationship with Wall Street it is
through the New York Fed that first of
all most of the bailout money came but
also historically that has had the
tightest relationship and a revolving
Board or between the board of the New
York Fed and leaders from Wall Street
right now for example Jamie Dimon has a
senior position on the board of the New
York Fed he runs a large large Bank JP
Morgan Chase he seceded sandy weill who
was running Citigroup which was you know
so there's this constant revolving door
and so if you're running off you're
president of the New York Fed you have
perhaps the closer relationship to Wall
Street than almost the chairman of the
Fed you know then even a Ben Bernanke
would happen why run the Fed jump into
the Fed let me let me mention something
to you last year I had been drank he
came before the Budget Committee and
this is during the whole bailout process
and so forth and as you know
well I want to get into this at some
length at the very least we know that
the Fed lent out over two trillion
dollars and zero interest loans to
financial institutions so I said through
Chairman Bernanke I said you know can
you tell the American people who got the
money it's you're putting their money at
risk most of us would like to know you
know some degree of transparent the
money and he said it was pretty amazing
he said not going to tell you two
trillion dollars of money and you're not
gonna tell the American people by the
time that day was over we had introduced
legislation to make them tell us and but
how talk a little bit about that how can
a head of the Fed say with a straight
face I'm not going to tell the American
people with two trillion dollars of
their money at risk has gone yeah no it
was astonishing because I think at the
same moment or a few minutes later he
said it would actually be
counterproductive right to tell people
and I remember the word
counterproductive as a how do you
possibly get to that term and I guess
the reasoning besides the fact there's a
whole lot of banks who don't want that
information disclosed because that would
indicate how weak they actually truly
are even with the bailout and with the
subsidies from the federal government
and I think Bernanke was basically using
that face and trying to somehow justify
it by saying well if people knew people
actually knew how weak their banks might
be we would have this catastrophic run
on the banks it would be breadlines 1933
all over again in the world would
totally collapse as we know it and I
think that whether he believes that or
not because I I personally think that
had we disclose this information from
the get-go from before the bailout
became as expensive as it became because
banks didn't know what each other hell
no one trusted anyone
and that's why credit tightened up and
we actually had full disclosure of books
back then of assets back then of what
the Fed might have been looking at back
then we could have avoided spending a
whole lot of money in this bailout but I
think by the time he got to that moment
he was so entrenched in the idea that if
anyone knows what actually went on it
would create it would it would create a
lot of anger but that I think was
probably as actual worry but he's what
he acted
if his worry was is that it would create
a runoff no that's exactly what he did
say but I think and by the way we took
that concept of the need for
transparency at the Fed for the floor of
the Senate during the budget discussion
and we won in a bipartisan vote because
I think it's very hard for the average
member of the Senate or the average
American to say excuse me you're putting
two trillion dollars of my money at risk
and you're not telling me who got it
maybe we need a 1-800 number everybody
in America gets zero interest loans and
you don't have we have a very different
America but I'll tell you one thing just
on the back of that the New York Fed
actually is extending more money than
and had more open plans to the banking
system then the Fed fake we're talking
about the two trillion on the feds book
ultimately there was about six trillion
worth of facilities created much of
which went through the New York feds
book and they don't necessarily
aggregate them all so there's a lot of
other stuff that's not even near being
looked at who knows about this stuff you
know some of it is it's it's quasi
public not not what collateral has been
posted and what banks have received how
much money that we are trying you are
trying to get to the bottom of that
information but when those facilities
were open when when they were created it
wasn't like there was a big media press
release but there is information that
you can kind of see through the you know
digging through the websites and I did
that I mean you can do it you could
write a book most of us probably know
you can't do it normally there's nowhere
you can go on a Fed website or the
Treasury website to say yeah what did
you spend where did you spend it how
much is it worth now when is it coming
back there there is no report that
exists like that I know what mayor steel
I'm gonna put you on the spot you ready
all right based on his record is head of
the New York Fed and now well let me get
to Bernanke do you think President Obama
poured forth Bernanke to be reappointed
to be head of the Fed do you think that
was a good decision I think that monkey
made a lot of mistakes during this this
this whole crisis leading up to it in
terms of not looking at the information
that other people could have looked at
and that there were economists telling
him about but more than that more than
that the Fed has the ability to reject
mergers the Fed has the ability to deny
applications for banks like Goldman
Sachs that are investment banks and
Morgan Stanley to become bank holding
companies which makes them more publicly
accessible to the Fed in terms of
receiving funds or receiving any sort of
subsidies or perks from the Fed it's
it's the feds job to be prudent about
that and when Ben Bernanke was in that
seat
he didn't say for a moment we shouldn't
have a merger between Merrill Lynch and
Bank of America he didn't say we
shouldn't have a merger between Wells
Fargo Maccabiah he didn't say why are we
backing Bear Stearns as assets in order
to have them merge into JP Morgan Chase
he didn't say any of that he didn't say
wait a minute goldman sachs you know
what you can't become a bank because you
have too much risk and we don't want the
government's money to back your risk he
he was in the position to do that that
was one of his jobs and he didn't do
that so I believe by not doing that he's
actually shoved a really big second
coming of the crisis may be delayed a
little bit but but created a much less
stable landscape than we even had before
last year's crisis so you're not one of
those folks who say well thank God
because of that decisive action in the
bailout man I we're over the hump now
good times are coming you don't accept
that right now there are some good times
coming for some banks because their
federal capital that they can use to go
back into taking risky positions and
trading and their stock is up and their
profits are up and their bonuses are up
but in actuality there's more risk and
there's more consolidation and there's
more power amongst a fewer group of
banks than there was before the crisis
so was there a crisis averted I think it
was delayed but that's the way I look at
it I think there are other decisions
that could have been made last fall they
wouldn't have involved putting trillions
of dollars of public capital behind that
banking system without changing
dramatically the landscape of that
backing of that banking system as we
speak president Obama has indicated that
those financial institutions that were
bailed out he's going to cut back very
substantially on the kind of CEO
compensation but the other financial
institutions like goldman sachs they're
running as quickly as they can back
before the crisis tell me about hoods
but if you like how do you a group of
people who caused this terrible crisis
and suffering for tens of millions of
people in this country after getting
bailed out by the taxpayers of this
country go back to huge compensation
packages and bonuses and go back to
exactly where they came from how do they
do that they feel incredibly
ridiculously entitled to doing that they
go back to their offices you know great
crisis averted let's go and make money
which they are Goldman Sachs is on track
to make twenty three billion dollars in
bonuses that year that's a couple more a
couple more billion dollars than they
made in the year before the crisis
they're actually doing better than they
were before and it's it's really this
this mentality of what we do here is
intense and it's important and it's this
moment and it's this trade and it's just
transaction and what happens on the
outside it's their fault it's their
fault for not being us you know it's you
know again as an elected official people
sometimes criticize appropriately
appropriately people in Congress living
in a inside the beltway mentality not
knowing what's going on I could tell you
that in my state of Vermont all over
this country there is fury there is rage
against these people and apparently
they're not interest about they they
don't care because nothing has happened
to them you know the rage and the
righteous rage of the of the public
doesn't affect what they get paid and it
hasn't affected how they operate they
said that their last quarterly earnings
moment they are gonna continue to do
what they do they do what they're very
open about it they're not even trying to
necessarily hide this information on
that note we're gonna take a break with
Nomi Prins whose excellent book it takes
the pillage explains I think to a lot of
people what has happened in the last
year and what's likely to happen in the
future we'll be back in a minute
and several other c-span programs are
available for download as podcasts more
with Nomi Prins and senator bernie
sanders in just a moment if you watch
book TV recently you've seen Gwen Ifill
author of breakthrough and senior
correspondent of the news hour with Jim
Lehrer on your television set Gwen with
the new book with your job do you have
time to read and what are you reading a
book I had no time to read anything that
had nothing to do with the book but now
that it's actually out I started reading
all kinds of things again I'm right in
the middle now of reading jamba stupid
spoke about the Antonin Scalia the just
Supreme Court justice I'm reading David
Plouffe spoke about the campaign of
course because he got to read those
books and I'm reading some fiction
there's a book I just finished called
trading dreams at midnight by Diane
McKinney wetstone who writes these
wonderful fictional stories about women
african-american women in the inner city
and so that was my fun book and it was
still kind of a downer what is your
preferred place in time to read I've
read I read a couple different ways I
read a lot on planes I have a Kindle so
I can carry around six different books
at one time that's good for traveling
and I read at home in my of a special
book chair that's dedicated just to
reading with a special task light and
and a whole basket full of books next to
it Gwen Ifill latest book is
breakthrough if you want to watch her
afterwards program where she was
interviewed interviewed by David Brooks
you can go to book TVO RG and go to the
afterwards archive and check it out
thanks so much thanks afterwards with
Nomi Prins and senator bernie sanders
continues
we're continuing our discussion with
Nomi Prins who's the author of it takes
a pillage Nomi it seems to I think many
Americans that we're living in a in a
world deeply divided a nation deeply
divided you've got a wall street up
there you and you use the phrase a sense
of entitlement these guys make hundreds
of millions a year occasionally a
billionaire you got hedge funds
operating they're doing that thing and
meanwhile you have the rest of the
country which has seen in many instances
really deep declines and people's
standard of living increase in poverty
people losing their health insurance so
you got Wall Street in what we call Main
Street what's the connection between the
two why does Wall Street get bail down
and get richer while people on Main
Street lose their jobs and their health
insurance and get poorer what's what's
that about and how do we turn that
around I think for one thing Wall Street
has a tighter connection to certain
people in in Washington and much more
money to lobby and everything else and
so there's there's a more there's more
of a sense of keeping what they have and
getting more there's no such thing as an
ethical Wall Street right now there's no
such thing as we're gonna stop ourselves
from making as much money as we possibly
can because that is there let me address
you just mention this thing which to me
is kind of astounding but that's the way
it is you would you might have thought
that the people on Wall Street who
caused this severe economic crisis
that's one of them one of these guys
might have gone on TV and said you know
Americans I'm really sorry our greed got
away from us and I know all of the
suffering with it we've caused I'm sorry
and we're going to change the way I
heard that no there's there's no
contrition there's no awareness there's
no connectivity to the rest of the
country because honestly the people that
really run these firms have almost no
contact literally they don't have a lot
of contact with real individuals but the
result of of the crisis that we all saw
last year in the bailout and just the
decision to open a lot of federal
funding and subsidies and guarantees and
cheap loans and everything to Wall
Street as if that would somehow trickle
down to the rest of Main Street it
almost had the opposite effect it kind
of it kind of fortified the standing
people in Wall Street in the
that survived to kind of continue to do
all the doing I mean let me interrupt
you to say that what you said is exactly
true the lines I've voted in I should be
clear I voted against the ballot but the
line was this is not a bailout for Wall
Street this is a bailout for Main Street
and working day and night to save Main
Street but you don't agree with that
assertion well not only do not agree
with the fact that is you didn't but I
also don't agree with any of the numbers
that we have shown that that have
legitimately indicated that this hasn't
been the case
credit did not loosen in fact when the
bailout was when tarp was passed and
that was only one component of the
bailout in the emergency economic
stabilization act there was a little
teeny piece of that act that also allow
the Fed to pay out more interest on
reserve money that the banks were
keeping with the Fed so while the banks
are getting money they're actually
incentivized to not do anything with it
while the Treasury secretary and others
are saying that this will somehow loosen
credit for the American people
it didn't credit is tighter now and as a
result unemployment is higher now
there's a direct correlation between
credit on that I'm a crazy credit and
you know if people sort of running up
but basically the idea of credit for
small businesses for medium businesses
for individuals because once those
companies can't make payroll they close
they fire people they don't have pot
they have nowhere else to go and and
also out of this crisis the smaller
banks are continuing to fail in sizeable
numbers we've had 99 closures just this
year of smaller banks while the bigger
banks are getting all of this capital so
even in the banking system there's
there's a wider gap and those smaller
banks feed a lot of the smaller loans
and the smaller businesses in the
individual so there's total knock-on
effect knockdown effect really of the
bottom part of the country that's why
foreclosures are now at a record quarter
again not last year this year were at a
record quarter this year there's more
defaults this year there's more
delinquencies this year people are
struggling more after the bail a year
after that intervention yes an
unemployment national unemployment was
five point eight percent preceding that
period of the crisis last fall and now
it is almost 10 percent and that doesn't
even clued the fact that in most cities
in urban areas 139 different urban areas
have double-digit unemployment from 15
15 before the crisis so not only has
this crisis not held Main Street is
actually hurt Main Street
so the bailout has hurt Main Street all
right what do we do what do we do to
create financial institutions that are
part of the United States of America
that don't live behind a wall of greed
and selfishness and irresponsibility and
illegal behavior what do we do to have
financial institutions play a role in
providing credit so that entrepreneurs
and business people can create real
goods and services and create meaningful
jobs what would you suggest that we do
well first of all we have to look at the
money that was given to the system and
because we didn't put the government
didn't put any strings attached to it we
actually have to start to attach some
strings and say you know what you said
you needed this you said you were going
to lose some credit
you didn't here's what you actually need
to do you need to take a proportion of
your capital and there's all this
discussion now and there should be about
banks having more capital so that they
can actually control their risk so the
government doesn't have to come in and
subsidize it but at the same time I
think some of that should be divided out
and more capital should be given to
those small businesses and more capital
should be made available and
renegotiation should be much easier
what's happening now is that not only is
credit not loosen but if someone wants
to renegotiate a home that's about to be
foreclosed upon and renegotiate their
mortgage you can't get it you can't get
anyone on the phone the process is so
exhausting and so cumbrous and and
documents get lost because there's just
no accountability along the way remember
these little loans became these many
assets and so up here it can't even find
where the actual deed was to a property
and I think you need to basically take a
look at that and make institutions more
accountable and there's a good reason to
do that now because they are sitting on
capital funding there's almost more of a
reason now to come in and say okay look
you had yours now here's what you need
to do you use the word accountability on
Wall Street that is a four-letter word
they don't like accountability but it
will never come
openly there no yeah Lloyd Blankfein's
the only he's not gonna like come to
Washington be like you know what we're
paying out twenty three billion in
bonuses this year I'm gonna cut that I'm
gonna just cut it down to a measly
fifteen billion and I'm gonna give the
rest of that money into some fun that's
gonna help small businesses or some fun
that's going
give credit or advisers or pay for them
to help people renegotiate their
mortgages I'm just I'm gonna do that
because I feel bad it will never happen
and so it means how it needs to be like
and particularly because they have had
public assistance almost it's almost to
ask more of Wall Street given that has
received so much more from from
standpoint of the federal government
even than it was before hand and I think
one of the things as a senator I hear a
lot about people can understand
understand how they're bailing out these
financial institutions and then they end
up paying 25 or 30 percent interest
rates on their credit cards which in the
old days used to be considered usury but
now is just the cost of their done
businesses it's it's it's the fees on
credit cards it's these arbitrary fees
that get slapped on checking accounts
and in savings accounts even in all
sorts of things because now it's really
a byproduct of glass-steagall repeal to
some extent to go back a little bit
explain for a moment I'm not sure all of
the viewers know what glass-steagall was
about what the repeal meant okay well in
1929 we had a tremendous stock market
crash in the United States which was
followed by the Great Depression and in
1933 when FDR was the president when he
came in basically in 1932 but in 1933
took office in the first couple days
what he did was he closed the banks
because it was noted that it was the
bank's fault it wasn't like people
spontaneously stopped paying it was that
credit tightened even back then
speculation was rampant even back then
products would be were being created
with nothing inside of them back then
the same sorts of things were happen and
that was because banks could take the
deposits of consumers the deposits of
the population and borrow against them
it's called leverage on Wall Street in
order to speculate and trade and they
did and so what glass-steagall was about
was saying you know what you cannot have
a financial institution that both has
the right in the access to population
deposits and makes loans to the
population and have them use that to bet
and gamble and speculate that that just
doesn't make any sense and particularly
the federal government cannot possibly
be able to back all of that risk it does
it sits
all kind of a black box and so a glass
steagle it is what it separated banks
out it said you know what if you want to
be a bank and you want to deal with
customers and you can get those deposits
your commercial bank you go over here we
will back you and the FDIC was created
at the same time in order to back the
deposits of consumers enough of
individuals in the United States
investment banks you know what you are
on your own you can do whatever you want
well maybe not totally whatever although
that has wooden what happened but you
you can you can speculate you can trade
you can do whatever but you know you we
don't have your back we're not gonna
back that risk the taxpayers are not
going to bail you out when you fail
right and that was just so logical and
and the FDIC won't be there to Tim back
you or to insure your debt which is kind
of what they're doing down with Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley it just it just
won't happen because it makes no sense
because when we came to the 80s in the
90s people like Alan Greenspan and Bob
Rubin proceeded to tell the Congress why
that was classic was just a terrible
destructive idea yeah from 1995 for four
years before appeal I remember Robert
Rubin was talking about this notion that
we couldn't be competitive as a nation
if our banks weren't allowed to do
whatever it is they do that the 1933
glass-steagall Act was antiquated it was
old it didn't work in today's modern
world of Finance and you just can't
constrict these because we're going to
be at a loss actually the United States
will actually decline in sort of
financial supremacy if we are not gonna
allow our banks to do what all the other
banks were doing so the Congress against
my vote repealed glass-steagall what was
the remediate result of it the immediate
result was a wave of mergers there were
mergers that actually preceded
glass-steagall such as Citigroup and
travelers there was an idea where
insurance companies could be apart now
commercial banks and investment banks
could be a part of commercial banks and
everything started merging together so
there was a first wave of mergers that
happened right after glass-steagall
and lobbying that year actually went
down because laughing was up the year
before lovely money went down so that
was there was a small temporary respite
on that but and and then what happened
is there was more consolidation for a
decade of the banking industry so that
you went from a situation where the top
banks had 20% of the assets and deposits
to now the top banks have 50% and and so
you just you just continue to
concentrate the industry and concentrate
it with more risk added to it and now
you have these banks using deposits of
as capital to speculate and trade just
like they did back in the 20s and that
takes us to the issue of too big to fail
yeah
and we're too big to fail means is is
that if a huge financial institution
goes under it's going to take half the
economy with it and then thus the
justification for having to bail them
out now it seemed to me and I said this
on the floor of the Senate that if an
institution is too big to fail it seems
to me that it's too big to exist but
since the bailout we have not seen a
break up of these large institutions
quite the contrary I don't know Paul
Volcker among others has raised that
issue what do you think about this too
big to fail what should we be doing I
think we should be going back to the the
current glass-steagall we should be
separating these banks back out again we
shouldn't have gotten it from a crisis
into a situation where there are now
fewer banks controlling more assets in
the country which goes back to what the
Fed was doing in terms of blessing those
mergers so we have a situation where we
need to separate them out we need to
separate out again the consumer deposits
and loans and assets from the
speculative investment banking and
trading because what we have right now
not only are those banks the big banks
bigger JP Morgan used to be distal just
AP Morgan Chase which had a lot of
mergers in it to begin with but then
having achieved the acquisition of Bear
Stearns it adds a really risky
investment bank Washington Mutual it
adds a whole bunch of consumer deposits
so now it's just this bigger animal
floating on more risk and that risk was
what we saw in their profits last
quarter there again no secret about this
the only reason they made money last
quarters not because consumers are doing
better consumers continue to post losses
because they continue to hurt where they
made money was in trading so I think we
have to totally take that risk out of
the government's responsibility to back
which means you have to break up these
bags so people want to speculate they
can go speculate but they're on their
own but they're not gonna get bailed out
by the government and if banks want to
make loans to people real people we will
back them up is what you're saying and
that makes so much sense because you
could not only will you back them up you
will understand the risk you
know exactly what you're dealing with I
don't think there's a lot of people in
in in Washington to sit there and look
at what a Creek an actual credit
derivative prospectus or a transaction
is you don't and it's complicated and I
think I think to some extent it's
actually not as complicated as it's made
out to be but it's certainly arcane and
to anyone who's not you know in the
trenches and and that's why it gets
that's why Wall Street gets away with
creating a lot of the securities it
creates it uses that lack of
understanding I think to its benefit let
me switch gear for a moment I I think
the average American after the bailout
during that period wanted to understand
how the crisis occurred who was
responsible for it and how we hold those
people accountable who's going to jail
who was apologizing we really haven't
seen a whole lot of that in fact one of
the issues that we fought for i-44 was a
real investigation well pakora you
explain to folks what the court the core
investigation was in 1932 well in 1932
pakora who was the assistant DA in New
York basically was asked to undergo an
investigation of predominantly the banks
and by the Senate Banking my the Senate
Banking Committee to basically look at
how what the practices of the banks that
were happening at that moment
contributed to the crash and contributed
to the depression and that was and and
what he found was this idea of
speculating on the back of nothing or on
the core JPMorgan and these other guys
and and and and he basically really
hammered them to explain exactly what
their practices were and exactly how
they inflated value and exactly what
they used what what deposits were or
money they used in order to do that and
it was so clear from that so clear that
this was something that was a direct
contributor of the crisis it wasn't that
and foreclosures were high than to
historically for that period but that
wasn't the crisis that was just a
manifestation of what Wall Street was
doing that the little individual home in
in Vermont or in Stockton California or
wherever the
the foreclosures on those are very very
difficult for the individuals but they
are not what brought the system down
brought the system down is all of the
speculation that the Wall Street mostly
investment banks created on the back of
those loans but the American people
really have not gotten that kind of
explanation of what happened they
haven't had the leading the guys who
caused this problem in front of the TV
cameras answering hard questions heavily
that and that's that's really a good
thing to do I mean some of these guys
have been in front of various committees
mostly talking about their bonuses and
there's a good thing and a bad thing
about that certainly the bonuses are
egregious particularly now after the
crisis and with federal funding beneath
them but if we just focus on the bonuses
we lose sight of the practices that
actually contributed to the bonuses so
you need to do both it and I agree it
will be really nice if you even got
these people in front to say they were
sorry but I mean I but even in addition
to that I think the American people are
owed an explanation of what happened and
then the understanding that the Congress
is trying to make sure that this doesn't
happen again but what I think you're
implying is these guys are very moving
very aggressively to bring us back to
exactly where we were before the the
financial collapse well absolutely
because one of the things that
contributed to them being allowed are
being able to create these assets out of
loans is that money was very cheap money
was very cheap under Greenspan actually
in 2001 in early 2002 as a result you
have more esoteric loans being given out
because banks are getting this money
cheap and they need to figure out how
they get more out of it so they
extracted from subprime or they
extracted by creating an asset or they
they find some way to create money from
nothing or money from cheap money and
now we have the exact same situation
rates are very low and in particular
banking system is getting like zero to
quarter of a percent loans from the Fed
so we're in a recreation of that
scenario just on a much grander scale
let me ask you another question changing
gear again a little bit um there is
growing
I think interest in the Fed itself which
as you've indicated today is an enormous
ly important institution but a very
secretive institution
you can argue that certainly in
particular moments Ben Bernanke the
chairman of the Fed is more powerful
than President Obama he controls more
money control he controls the ability to
create money that is a very powerful
ability talk a little bit about the Fed
how does somebody like the chairman of
the Fed get all of this power what do we
know about the Fed should there be more
transparency in the Fed night I have to
admit that I am the author of the Senate
bill which calls for a Gao audit of the
Fed to do all of these things a little
prejudice than asking this question but
I think whether you're you know you're a
conservative you're a progressive as I
am people just kind of shaking their
heads that an institution with so much
power can operate in so much secrecy
what do you think and and also
subsidized so much of a private sector
and an reside in Washington and I think
I think to a large extent the Fed in
this particular situation has totally
overstepped even its mandate and even
what it was designed to do the Fed is
supposed to on a regular working day you
know control yeah are basically set
interest rate it's supposed to set
something called monetary policy it's
supposed to raise rates lower rates
depending on whether or not money is
easy or harder to flush into the the
general system be used for current it be
used for businesses or or what have you
and they do that it's also supposed to
oversee these commercial banks it's
supposed to make decisions as to whether
they are allowed to become bigger if
there are risks within them it is
actually supposed to go in and say
something the fact is it doesn't because
it has such a tight relationship with
Wall Street with the banking system that
it's almost like telling on your brother
do you happen to know how many people
there are on the Fed how these guys
appointed well there's there's 12
Federal Reserve banks there they're
appointed basically people are appointed
through those banks so for example the
New York Fed sort of appoints people
from its back door which is which is
Wall Street and therefore you have a
board of the Fed which which controls to
some extent how this money goes back to
where they came from to one extent last
year Stephen Friedman who was chairman
of the board of the Fed at the the New
York Fed where where Tim Geithner was
president was at the same time on the
board of directors at Goldman
Saxe so you're basically you've got your
foot on the place that you can get money
from and you've got the foot in the door
of the place that gets benefits not an
expression for that it's called an
enormous conflict of interest it is a
tremendous con from day one the Fed was
a conflict of interest from day one
particularly the New York Fed and I mean
the relationship is that the New York
Fed is the most powerful of those 12
feds but from day one that's a conflict
there should not be members of that
board on the board who are in any way
related to the banks that receive any
kind of money from from the Fed
otherwise called a bank that would be a
private bank but but don't let it have
access to the ability to create public
money now how do in your judgment these
guys with so much power
playing literally with trillions of
dollars get away without the kind of
public scrutiny I made the point you
know that when you're on the floor of
the Senate you're fighting for twenty
eight million dollars there could be a
six hour debate oh you don't need that
money it's only fly meanwhile very
quietly these guys say well we're gonna
provide trillions of dollars in zero
interest no discussion nobody knows who
gets it
how do we what's going on well I think
to some extent and and you're different
but at the time I think there was an
idea of well the economy's is going out
of control it's spiraling downward
something needs to be done and for some
reason the Fed will know what to do and
so there wasn't as much question there
was so much debate over the bailout over
the 700 billion dollars and there wasn't
any questioning at the time over what's
been going on on the Fed's balance sheet
and I think to some extent there needs
to be and certainly in the auditing
bills are the way to do that and and
extend opening what they're doing to the
public is a way to do that there needs
to be a required accountability to
Congress because it's public money
period how do you live in a democratic
society where public officials are
supposed to be held accountable 'ti
without any kind of knowledge yeah it's
it's it's it's it's wrong I think I
think what we've seen out of this this
scenario in particular is that the Fed
should not be an sort of isolated
private secretive organization if it's
going to be involved in huge raising of
public funds in order to subsidize a
private industry it needs to publicly
disclose what it's doing it is bizarre
that that so much conversation is given
over 28 million dollar additions to help
anything
he almost like it's like a shell game
that we're gonna have all these great I
mean there are great debates really on
the floor of the Senate about a hundred
thousand dollar earmark that goes on
hour after hour after hour and then you
get trillions of dollars being lent out
here with no discussion whatsoever at
one point the amount of money that the
Fed had on offer to the banking industry
was eight trillion dollars now it's six
it is six trillion dollars worth of open
possibility I'm not saying every bank
has used all that we don't know but but
there is an open possibility of six
trillion dollars worth of money I mean
that's just it's staggering it is and
then you also debate over stimulus
package or if extending unemployment
benefits or saying and and the numbers
aren't even in the same zip code all
right let me we're rapidly running out
of time but this has been a fascinating
discussion and I'm glad your your father
made your major in mathematics or
something it sounds like a use that
background very productive why don't we
conclude our discussion where do you
think the president and the Congress
should go what would you like to see
them do right now well the first thing I
think they should have a real debate
over to this idea of too big to fail I
think by simply increasing capital
limits and having these too big to fail
banks be sort of watched better it is
not the way to go because you're
watching something you don't understand
I think we need to break them up
reinstate glass-steagall make them
smaller you know and and I think that
will have the added benefit of reducing
risk in the system because then we know
we're actually dealing with and then you
can control compensation which is
created out of the risk-taking and out
of the bonuses that come from those
profits because you're subdue a risk in
the system and yes bankers won't make as
much money but that's okay know me we're
running out of time but I think the main
point that you have made maybe the most
important point of many many very good
employment points is that we can't look
at Wall Street or something separate
from
middle-class and working families of
this country that we can't continue a
process for where these guys live in
their own world do not invest in
anything of productive value while the
middle class continues to shrink and
unemployment goes up that they've got to
play a different different kind of a
role exactly and we can't make it up to
them that that's the key thing
President Obama's talking about raising
small business loan caps and that is
good but if the banks don't want to
extend the loans it doesn't matter that
the caps are higher so there has to be
an attachment there has to be an actual
legislative attachment to making this
behavior occur all right on that note
let me thank Nomi Prins for being with
us
the book is an excellent book and I
can't think of a subject matter which is
more important for us to be engaged in
Nomi thanks very much for being with us
thank you very much senator every year
the National Press Club hosts an author
night tonight we're here with Robert
McKinnon author of actions speak loudest
keeping our promise for a better world
Robert you're the president the yellow
brick of yellow brick road tell us a
little about that it's a company in New
York that designed social change we
address issues range from childhood
obesity to climate change and our work
is all around communications
social change advocacy and action that's
the book so that was your impetus for
writing the book that you have a lot of
different contribute in this book I see
everyone from Bill McKim and McKibben on
the left and Newt Gingrich on the right
how do you decide on the contributors
yeah well you know the the whole impetus
behind the book was this idea that we
may be the first generation of adults
who don't leave their children a better
world and we inherited and that's not a
partisan issue that's something where
there are a lot of things they're
conspiring that we need to address
ranging from childhood obesity to
climate change to health and healthcare
debates that we're having right now and
we're open for all kinds of opinions
regardless of political affiliation I
mean though you know ideas don't
necessarily have to be partisan so we
wanted to go ahead and find people who
we thought had great ideas and great
solutions now give me an example of one
of these contributors tell me about what
they
and why sure well you know as you
mentioned there's a lot of really big
names in the book from President Jimmy
Carter to Queen Noor but to me some of
the much better chapters who are most
inspiring were those by people who
really had dealt with an issue firsthand
so who better to write about violence
than Richard cast Aldo who was paralyzed
the Columbine and to hear him talk about
how violence infects our society was
really moving or when you talk about the
issue of the role of parents and fathers
and mothers who had Juan Williams who
wrote an incredible piece on
disappearing fathers and in kids lives
along Williams is a co-author of the
book correct yeah yeah he's been
wonderful to work with
he's a banty but he wrote both the
chapter as well as the introduction and
one of things we talk about the
contributor said I think he summed up
really nicely is that what's nice about
this book or there are people who
basically put their hands in the muck
and mire of life and decided to make
something beautiful out of it a better
outcome for our children our MacKinnon
author of actions speak loud as
president of yellowbrickroad thank you
thank you very much have a great day
biographer Harlow Unger recounts the
life of James Monroe the fifth President
of the United States President Monroe
served two terms was a decorated soldier
in the Revolutionary War and held more
public positions than anyone else in
American history Harlow Unger recalls
James Monroe's political career at
borders books in New York City this is
50 minutes
thank you very much I'm truly honored to
be here tonight I want to thank my
publisher to capo press and Perseus
books for making this evening possible
my thanks to two c-span television and
Borders bookstore a landmark here at
57th Street in Park Avenue in New York
City I'm particularly honored by the
presence of several renowned authors and
wonderful and I was Fleming whose latest
book is a biography of Martin Luther
King jr. a dream of hope the naval
historian paul silverstone is here
tonight and one of America's great
historians is here Thomas Fleming his
new book just out is called the intimate
lives of the founding fathers I wonder
what that's about
I'm particularly honored by having you
all here because I know that some of you
sacrificed the $15,000 plate fundraiser
for President Obama tonight I can only
offer you food for thought but the price
is right I'm sure you've all seen the
famous painting of George Washington
Crossing the Delaware and you probably
remember there's a soldier standing
behind him with the American flag in his
arms
well that soldier that officer is James
Monroe and there were two symbolic
reasons that the artist John Trumbull
placed Monroe with Washington as one of
the only two important figures in the
painting one of the only two figures
standing in that boat now Monroe didn't
actually cross the Delaware in the same
boat as Washington but Trumbull put him
there to show him as the great hero